you may not realize it but you use
mathematical models
every day something as simple as the
weather forecast is actually a complex
model based on countless data points
[Music]
today prediction models are critical to
coronavirus planning covit 19 is still
new
and it's hard to anticipate how it will
spread and whom it will affect
models can give scientists government
officials and doctors previews
of how to stop the virus and save lives
welcome to our covered 19 special i'm
monica jones and to some extent i've
contributed to prediction models today
by
getting tested just like all the anchors
here it's a precaution
but those tests on individuals are
costly a researcher in wonder
came up with an efficient alternative
in the battle against the pandemic
rwanda's coronavirus task force relies
on comprehensive contact tracing
to get an up-to-date picture of how much
the coronavirus has spread
rwanda tests a cross-section of the
population regularly
using an ingenious strategy called pool
testing
the brains behind the strategy is
wilfred nadifan
a professor at the african institute for
mathematical science
if you go to the community and test
people
it doesn't tell you how many people are
actually infected
right because you can test everybody so
you always sample
and so to go from the sample to the
truth to reality you need mathematical
models
the calculations involve complex
algorithms
defon has translated them for us into an
example from everyday life
the idea behind protesting is really
simple so imagine that you have nine
cups of beans and you're told that one
of those cups has bad beans
and in order to check which cup has the
bad beans you must cook the beans
and test so you might find that the
beans taste bitter
those who have cooked beans they know
that it takes a long time for beans
to get well cooked and so you use a lot
of gas if you're doing nine
cooking nine pots of beans to avoid this
effort the mathematician resorts to a
simple yet efficient trick
he combines bean samples from different
pots
if all the beans in this pool are good
he no longer has to test each pot
individually
only if there are bitter beans in the
sample must he perform
additional tests the principle can be
applied any time
groups are tested and it can be used to
combat kovitt 19.
in rwanda sets of 10 and 20 samples are
combined and tested simultaneously
if the pool test result is negative all
the subjects in the pool
sample are indicated as not having covit
19.
but if the pooled result is positive
each sample is re-tested
individually the advantages of the
pulling approach is just
to reduce the cost spent today
for the reagents to reduce the
turnaround time
feedback for results and also to test
massively
in the community or also the group which
are just
which are that concerned for the coffee
19. so those are the main advantages for
this
if the virus has spread dramatically
pooled samples test positive too
often and re-testing becomes costly and
time-consuming
so far however africa has low number of
cases compared to western countries
and the method is proving useful there
this is really helpful for the african
countries but not only african countries
even for developing countries since we
developed this and they published the
pulling approach in the nature paper so
we have been
approached by several countries ghana
and kenya are now applying the strategy
to mass testing
inquiries have also come from the us and
in britain
the university of edinburgh is testing
students with this method
oliver radman is a lecturer and
statistic in the department of
mathematics at
imperial college london uh welcome to
our program and before we get into the
nitty-gritty of mathematical modelling
just very very briefly
what exactly is it that you do at your
department
hi thanks for having me today so i'm
part of the imperial
um college london covet 19 response team
and we've looked at you know um various
kinds of infectious disease models to
inform
on public health responses to the
epidemic i guess
the the first and probably one of the
most important pieces was
where we have planned out scenarios on
what would prevent
um hospitals to collapse and what
prevent
hundreds of thousands of deaths in the
population so there was the first one
and we showed it so it's resistancing
um general lockdowns on capping of
non-essential services are really
fundamental to that
later on we looked at the age groups
that sustained the epidemic showing that
it's primarily the 20 to 49 years that
drive spread
um 70 of all transmissions occurring
from
those individuals with limited um our
contributions from
school-age children and and more
recently we looked at the spread of b117
um in england and p1 in brazil
and we showed for b117 that it's uh
by effect of 1.5 to 1.6 more
transmissible
than the current variants that are
currently circulating
when you say you look at all these
things what exactly does this mean i
mean
talk us through the process for example
of what you've been doing in brazil
so where we start by you know analyzing
the the real um real-time data as it
comes in and is reported
so in this case it's a case data
initially it was case
data from from the now's hospital data
such as number of admissions um a number
of deaths
variable data on status exams um as you
know it's been horrific
in in the amazon um and then we try to
interpret
interpret this data with mathematical
models so these are
um non-linear models so they are it's a
little bit
unintuitive to uh to work with them it's
not like
um i throw you a ball and you know where
it lands so
so we really need these models to help
us understand what's going on
and and how do you translate those
models that are not linear
uh for policymakers to understand what's
going on so that they can
decide on specific measures
well we show you know the um the fits to
the data
um itself along with uh 95 percent
credible intervals
to measure uncertainty we show forecasts
you know
various what if scenarios and there is
no single forecast right
um um but but they're different
scenarios what would happen
if you know if mobility were to reduce
in the population
what you know and other things um
and um and then based on that you know
based on that communication and
verification from several teams
different analysis from different
regions um ultimately decisions
are being made at a policy level i mean
let's
take a concrete example because here in
germany there's a lot of discussions
right now politicians are talking about
how to end the lockdown
now if german chancellor angela merkel
came to you and
asked you what happens uh to the
infection rate
if we were to open schools and
restaurants next week
could you provide her with a model oh
you know um
yes so that is what we've been doing
like day in and day out for the past
year for the british government um and
it's just not us
but it's like more than 10 other
modeling teams and institutions across
the uk who come together and feed back
into this
and and so it's a um it's a very busy
it's been a very busy period i i bet uh
but
are they actually then taking uh well
you're not giving advice you give them a
model
so uh they still have to sort of figure
out what it means and make the right
policy decision
uh can you support them somehow we may
be trying to make the story to it
but we're trying to really make this as
transparent and and easily accessible as
possible
so you know we give them graphs and we
give timelines and
projections um and confidence is built
by having very similar answers from very
different types of models
and being also transparent about the
assumptions that undergo you know and
underline all these models
all right so you're inexpensible these
days certainly but
when the pandemic is over if it's over
one day
what models would you like to work on
well you know like occupied 19 is not
the only infectious disease out there in
the world in fact like i'm you know
primarily working on hiv
there's you know many other diseases um
you've heard about alien influenza in
the first cases you know first human
transmissions um
um already happened this year so uh
there's no shortage of problems to to
work on
uh i'm afraid you're right yes oliver
radman from
imperial college in london thank you so
much for your time
switching cognitive gears now you'll see
what i mean over to derek
how much of the population has to be
vaccinated before we reach
herd immunity everyone
wants to know this number which from the
start has generally been
estimated at roughly 70 of the
population
um the problem is that pinning it down
exactly
isn't possible yet because there's still
so many moving parts in this pandemic um
two
of the most important factors that can
have a major
impact on herd protection are still
big question marks um the first is the
extent to which people who've been
vaccinated can still potentially catch
and transmit the disease even if they
never develop
symptoms themselves the data we have so
far
on this aspect is is quite positive
evidence
from a couple of larger studies now in
peer review
indicates that at least some approved
vaccines
appear to help lower a recipient's
chances
of being a transmitter after being
vaccinated
maybe dramatically the second factor
that plays a key role
in how soon we reach herd protection
involves
variants when the virus mutates
to become more transmissible people who
get it
grow more contagious so they give it to
more people
on average and that makes achieving
herd protection more difficult another
potentially
problematic facet of this problem is
that that variants
can also mutate in ways that lower
existing immune protection to sars cov2
whether for those who've been vaccinated
or for those who've had the disease
so variants could turn people we thought
were protected
back into potential infectors despite
the imponderables
many see falling case numbers in
countries
with high vaccination rates as evidence
that herd protection is already
beginning to influence
the course of the pandemic but we won't
really know we have it
until we get there
that's it thanks for watching
you